Je voudrais vous remercier encore une fois pour nous rejoindre dans cette conférence.
Il y a tellement de travail qui est impliqué dans ce type de conférence.
Merci beaucoup à toutes les femmes qui ont aidé avec la nourriture, les plants. Il y a tellement de choses que personne ne peut même voir.
Myra a beaucoup travaillé.
Et j'apprécie beaucoup tout son travail.
Oui, je vais prier pour qu'on puisse commencer.
Je veux que tu puisses ouvrir nos cœurs, nous donner l'acceptation de ta parole, la force pour l'obéir.
Et encore une fois, c'est notre gratitude, notre reconnaissance à toi pour tout ce que tu es en train de faire.
Seigneur, bénis ce moment.
Pardonne-nous nos péchés et que nous puissions glorifier ton nom à travers tout cela.
Au nom de Jésus.
Dans la première section, nous avons vu comment le Seigneur a créé la femme spécialement pour être une aide pour son mari.
Dans cette deuxième session, on m'a demandé de partager sur le rôle de la femme en tant que aide à leur mari dans le ministère.
Je suis sûre que plusieurs d'entre vous ont déjà entendu parler d'une enseignante américaine très connue qui s'appelle Nancy Lee DeMoss Wigelmuth.
Nancy et moi étions très proches lorsque nous étions jeunes avant qu'elle soit si connue et fameuse.
Et elle m'a raconté qu'un jour, elle est rentrée dans son bureau et elle a trouvé deux publicités sur son bureau.
Une était pour une entreprise de publication et de papeterie et une autre pour une grande chaîne de magasins de vêtements.
Et sur le haut de ces deux annonces, il y avait ces mots-là dans des lettres très grandes et boldes.
Gras.
It's all about you.
Tout est à propos de vous.
Et isn't that what we're told all the time?
Et c'est exactement, n'est-ce pas, ce que le monde nous dit tout le temps.
Our own sinful hearts speak that to us.
Nos propres cœurs pécheurs nous disent ça.
And the world around us tells us that all the time.
Et le monde autour de nous nous dit ça tout le temps.
It's all about you.
C'est tout à propos de vous.
You must fight for your rights.
Vous devez défendre vos droits.
You deserve to have things your way.
Vous méritez d'avoir les choses de votre façon.
You have to look out for yourself first.
Vous devez d'abord penser à vous-même.
But that is not the attitude we are encouraged to have in Scripture.
Mais cela n'est pas l'attitude que nous sommes encouragés à avoir dans les Écritures.
And if that is our attitude, it will not only hinder our ministry, but it will hinder our husband's ministry.
Et si cela est notre attitude, ça va non seulement entraver notre ministère, mais celui de nos maris aussi.
Le Seigneur Jésus a dit à ses propres disciples,
Quiconque veut être grand parmi vous, qu'il soit votre serviteur.
And whoever would be first among you, must be your slave.
Et quiconque veut être le premier parmi vous, qu'il soit votre esclave.
Even the Son of Man came not to be served, but to serve and to give his life a ransom for many.
C'est ainsi que le Fils de l'homme est venu, non pour être servi, mais pour servir et donner sa vie comme la ransom de plusieurs.
The Lord Jesus was the most humble servant who has ever lived.
Jésus était le serviteur le plus humble qu'il n'ait jamais vécu.
Il a nourri les affamés.
Il a guéri les malades.
Il a consolé les affligés.
Il a lavé les pieds sales de ses disciples.
Et nous sommes appelés à l'imiter.
Je pense qu'il serait très bon pour tout chrétien de mémoriser le passage en Philippiens 2, versets 3 à 8.
Et je vais vous lire ce verset.
On nous dit de ne faire rien par rivalité ou...
Vain de gloire.
Cela veut dire qu'à l'église, nous ne devons pas être en train de faire une compétition avec personne.
Nous sommes dit de compter les autres comme étant plus importants, plus signifiants que nous-mêmes.
Cela inclut nos maris.
Cela inclut nos membres de nos familles.
Nous devons servir aux autres personnes.
Quelle humiliante réflexion de penser que notre précieux Sauveur, Dieu lui-même un cher, a pris la forme le plus bas des serviteurs.
Il a pris la forme du plus bas des serviteurs.
Et il a donné sa vie pour nous.
Et nous pensons que nous sommes justifiés à réclamer notre propre façon de faire les choses ?
Voulez-vous avoir l'esprit du Christ, la pensée du Christ ?
Moi, je le veux.
J'ai beaucoup de travail devant moi encore.
Mais je veux être comme Jésus.
Est-ce que nous sommes prêts à nous humilier et à regarder aux autres comme étant plus importants que nous-mêmes ?
Et ça commence par le mari.
Et vous savez, quand nous marchons en humilité, nous nous trouverons reconnaissants pour n'importe quelle opportunité que Dieu nous donne pour servir.
Nous serons contents de prier avec une soeur qui a douleur.
Nous pouvons avec joie garder encore une fois la garderie le dimanche.
Nous sommes honorés de préparer des repas pour ceux qui ont besoin.
On peut même trouver de la joie à frotter des toilettes.
Mon mari et moi sommes des membres d'une petite église au Alabama.
Et dans une petite église, chacun doit faire sa part, son travail.
Quand je suis dans ma ville, très souvent, je nettoie les toilettes dans le bâtiment de notre église.
C'est une petite façon de servir à mes frères et soeurs.
Si nous arrivons plus tôt dans le bâtiment de l'église, ce n'est pas rare de trouver mon mari passé l'aspirateur dans le sanctuaire là où il est à l'occulte.
Il est un ancien dans notre église, mais il comprend que nous sommes tous appelés à être des serviteurs.
Et si vous cultivez un esprit de service, vous allez véritablement trouver du plaisir à servir.
Et quand nous servons avec de la joie, quelle bénédiction cela est pour nos maris.
Pour notre famille.
Et pour le corps du Christ.
Donc comment pouvons-nous encourager nos maris dans leur ministère ?
Nous encourageons nos maris à devenir un meilleur serviteur en cherchant à l'aider à réussir.
Nous avons tous entendu la femme exceptionnelle de Proverbe 31 qui est louée et présentée comme un modèle pour nous.
Mais vous savez, il y a un acteur important dans cette partie des écritures et plusieurs fois on ne le voit même pas.
Il m'est mentionné que deux fois dans les 22 versets qui décrivent la femme excellente.
Mais ce qui est dit par rapport à lui éclaire beaucoup par rapport au caractère de cette femme incroyable.
Après que nous avons entendu de ses achats qui sont très sages.
Ses travaux infatigables pour sa famille, pour la communauté, pour ceux qui sont dans le besoin.
Ça nous parle de sa foi et de sa bonté et de sa sagesse.
Et après tout ça, les Écritures ne nous disent pas qu'elle était connue aux portes de la Bible.
Elle n'était pas connue dans les lieux de proéminence.
Where the leaders would assemble.
Où les dirigeants se rassemblent.
No, the scripture tells us her husband was known in the gates when he sits among the leaders of the land.
Non, les Écritures nous disent que son mari est connu aux portes de la ville lorsqu'il se siège parmi les anciens du pays.
As you read through Proverbs 31, that verse almost seems out of place.
I mean, the entire passage is describing this wonderful woman.
And yet he is the one known in place prominence.
You see, this wife was joyfully carrying out her role as a helper to her husband.
We never see her promoting herself or trying to climb the ladder of success.
She poured all of her efforts into helping to make her husband successful.
And I believe this lady's outstanding work and her godly character
helped her husband carry out his responsibilities.
We have a saying in my country, behind every successful man
is a good woman and a surprised mother-in-law.
I don't know about that, but I do know that a woman can help a man succeed
or she can contribute to his failure.
The work of the woman in Proverbs 31
was not in the public spotlight.
Most of it was done behind the scenes.
The work of the woman was done behind the scenes.
But it strengthened and freed her husband to serve in a public position.
And if you are a married woman, one of the greatest things you can do
is to encourage your husband in his endeavors.
And very often that's done without commendation or recognition.
But what a tremendous benefit to our husbands.
I love the attitude of the virtuous woman in Proverbs 31.
She did not look after all of her responsibilities because she had to.
She did not do all of her responsibilities because she was forced to do.
But verse 13 tells us she willingly worked with her hands.
But in verse 13, it says that she worked with pleasure.
The Hebrew word literally means to work with pleasure or delight.
It seems that she joyfully put her heart into her work.
It seems that she met her heart with joy in her work.
And you know, sisters, our attitude and our service is of paramount importance.
We do not have to cook and clean and do laundry for our families.
We get to serve the people we love the most.
We do not have to labor in the church.
We get to serve our brothers and sisters.
We have been given a great privilege to serve our dear families.
As well as the church of the Lord Jesus Christ.
We must be so careful that we don't lose sight of what a privilege we have been given.
We must be so careful that we have been given.
Are you seeking to help your husband in his walk with God?
Are you seeking to help him in his role as the head of your home?
Est-ce que vous cherchez à l'aider dans son rôle en tant que chef de votre maison?
And in the ministry that God has called him to.
Et dans le ministère auquel Dieu l'a appelé.
Now, when you have small children, it's difficult to be as involved in your husband's ministry
as you would like to be.
Lorsqu'on a des jeunes enfants, c'est plus difficile d'être aussi impliqué dans le ministère de nos maris
que ce qu'on aimerait faire.
But you can be such an encouragement to him as you joyfully carry out your role.
As a submissive, devoted, loving wife and mother.
Comme une femme et une mère soumise et dévouée et pleine d'amour.
Et le Seigneur vous aidera.
Quand mes quatre enfants étaient plus petits, on ne voyageait pas avec mon mari.
Mon mari voyageait beaucoup.
Et moi, je restais à la maison avec les quatre enfants.
Et cela était avant les téléphones portables.
Et on n'avait pas d'argent.
Et à l'époque, on devait payer pour appeler à des lieux lointains.
Donc, nous parlions une fois par semaine au téléphone.
Et vous savez, il y avait des époques où c'était dur.
Mais ça me faisait appeler ou crier au Seigneur.
Et il m'a toujours aidée.
Et il m'a donné tellement de joie dans mon appel en tant que mère et femme.
Même dans ces saisons difficiles.
Parce que je savais que j'étais en train de libérer mon mari pour faire ce que Dieu l'avait appelé à faire.
Et nous devons nous demander à nous-mêmes, est-ce que nous nous voyons en tant qu'aide de nos maris ?
Ou est-ce que je le vois principalement comme mon aide, mon assistant ?
Encore une fois, quand on a des petits-enfants, il y a des fois où tout le monde doit aider.
Mais nous devons demander au Seigneur d'examiner notre attitude.
Est-ce que j'ai un cœur qui désire être une aide pour mon mari ?
Ou est-ce que j'attends constamment qu'il laisse de côté ce qu'il fait pour venir m'aider ?
Donc un des moyens les plus importants que vous pouvez aider vos maris, c'est de demander au Seigneur de vous donner un cœur de serviteur.
De demander au Seigneur de vous permettre de marcher en humilité lorsque vous servez votre famille et d'autres.
Priez pour une plus grande appréciation et compréhension du ministère de votre mari.
Une femme chrétienne peut aussi aider son mari dans le ministère en importance de l'honneur à son nom.
Nous voyons ça en Proverbe 12, verset 4.
Une femme vertueuse est la couronne de son mari.
Mais celle qui fait honte est comme la pourriture dans ses os.
Quel contraste !
Just as a crown signifies royalty,
tout comme une couronne signifie la royauté,
a godly wife brings honor to her husband.
Une femme pieuse honore son mari.
You see, a wise woman builds her husband up,
and in that, she strengthens her entire family.
Vous voyez, une femme sage, elle édifie son mari,
et en le faisant, elle apporte de la force pour toute sa famille.
But a foolish, self-centered woman brings her husband down.
Mais une femme folle et centrée sur elle-même,
elle abaisse son mari.
Et dans ce process, elle déshonore sa famille.
A wise, godly woman can enable a man
to reach his full potential in service for the Lord.
Une femme sage et pieuse peut permettre à un homme
d'atteindre tout son potentiel dans son service pour le Seigneur.
Dieu m'a sauvée dans ma première année à l'université.
And I was attending a Bible college.
I didn't know anything about the Bible.
I didn't have a clue how to be a godly woman.
So I started reading books and studying the Scripture.
Donc j'ai commencé à lire des livres et à étudier de la parole.
And I took a class in my college on biblical womanhood.
Et donc à mon université, j'ai suivi un cours sur la féminité biblique.
The teacher of that class made a statement one day
that I have never forgotten,
even though it's been almost 50 years since I heard it.
She said, young women, when you marry,
never forget that it is within your power
to make or break your husband.
And after being in ministry and traveling a lot
for almost five decades,
I have repeatedly seen the truth of that statement.
J'ai vu cette vérité s'est réalisée plusieurs fois.
My husband has preached in many churches
where the pastors were dynamic speakers.
Mon mari, il a prêché dans plusieurs églises
où les pastors étaient des prédicateurs dynamiques.
They were excellent administrators.
Ils étaient des excellents administrateurs.
And faithful shepherds over their flock.
Et des bergers dévoués sur leur bergerie.
Trupeaux, sur leur troupeau, pardon.
I'm sorry.
They didn't know the problem.
Their ministries were greatly hindered
because their wives were either uncommitted
or they were difficult to live with.
Mais leur ministère était très intravé
parce que leur femme n'était pas engagée
dans leur ministère
ou alors difficile à vivre avec.
On the other hand,
we've served with many pastors
who were not nearly as gifted.
Et dans l'autre côté,
nous avons aussi vu plusieurs pastors
qui n'étaient pas aussi doués.
But their ministries flourished
because they had wives
who were committed
and supportive of their ministries.
parce qu'ils avaient des épouses
qui étaient pieuses
et qui soutenaient leur ministère énormément.
1 Corinthians 11, 7
tells us that the man
is the image and glory of God.
1 Corinthians 11, 7
nous dit que l'homme
est l'image et la gloire des dieux.
but the woman
is the glory
of the man.
but the woman
is the glory of the man.
The woman being the glory of the man
reflects God's order of authority
in the church.
La femme étant la gloire de l'homme
reflète l'ordre de Dieu
dans l'église.
The man was created
to manifest the authority
and the will of God.
L'homme a été créé
pour manifester l'autorité
et la volonté de Dieu.
And in that way,
he is the glory of God.
Et dans cette façon-là,
il est la gloire de Dieu.
Now the woman was also created
in the image of God.
Maintenant,
la femme a aussi été créée
à l'image de Dieu.
But she isn't called
the glory of God.
She's called
the glory of the man.
That's because
she is to display
the authority
and will of the man.
As a Christian woman
yields herself
to the designated
order of authority,
she becomes
the glory of the man.
Lorsqu'une femme chrétienne
se soumet
à l'ordre d'autorité
qui lui a été dessinée,
elle devient
la gloire de l'homme.
God created Eve
to help Adam
carry on
his responsibilities.
Dieu a créé Eve
pour aider Adam
à accomplir
ses responsabilités
qui lui ont été données.
And as each of them
fulfilled the roles
that God
had created them for,
they brought
glory to God.
and when
they filled
the role
for which
God
created them,
they reflected
the glory of God.
Proverbs 31, 11
tells us that
the heart
of the virtuous
woman's husband
trusted in her.
Proverbs 31, 11
dit que le cœur
du mari
de la femme
virtueuse
a confiance
en elle.
You see,
regardless of what
happened,
he knew
that she would
stand with him.
Vous voyez,
il savait que
peu importe
ce qui se passait,
il savait
qu'elle serait
à ses côtés.
She would help him.
Elle l'aiderait.
She would always do
what was in his best interest.
Elle ferait toujours
ce qui était
dans son meilleur intérêt.
He could confide
in her
knowing that
she would
not disclose
his private matters.
Il pouvait se confier
à elle
en toute sécurité
sachant qu'elle
n'allait pas
partager
ses affaires privées.
She would take
every opportunity
to do him good.
Elle allait prendre
toute opportunité
pour lui faire du bien.
And Proverbs 31, 12
says she does him good
and not harm
all the days
of her life.
Et Proverbs 31, 12
dit qu'elle lui fait
du bien
et non du mal
tous les jours
de sa vie.
This conscientious wife
not only did good
for her husband,
cette femme consciencieuse
non seulement faisait
du bien
à son mari,
but she did not do
anything
that would harm him
or hinder him
in his work.
Mais elle ne faisait
rien qui pourrait
le nuire
ou l'entraver
dans son rôle.
She was a crown
to her husband.
Elle était
une couronne
pour son mari.
Years ago,
my husband and I
were serving
in Germany
and we had
the joy
of going
to the home
of Martin Luther,
the father
of the Protestant
Reformation.
And I was amazed
to find out
what a busy lady
Catherine Luther
had been.
and I was amazed
to find out
how much
her husband
Catherine Luther
was a
very busy
and she took
care of
their six children.
She took care
of their six children.
Seven nieces
and nephews
that the Luthers
adopted.
Seven nieces
and neveux
que Luther
adopted.
Four orphans
that they adopted.
Quatre orphans
qu'ils avaient
adopted.
Katie's aunt
and tutors
and students
from the university.
And many
religious refugees
and visitors
that would come
to see her husband.
Et plusieurs
réfugiés religieux
et visiteurs
qui venaient
pour connaître
son mari.
She oversaw
a huge garden.
Elle gérait
un énorme jardin.
And she bred
and sold cattle
to provide
for their family.
Et elle élevait
et vendait
du bétail
pour pouvoir
pourvoir
à sa famille.
When there was
widespread illness
she operated
a hospital
in their home.
Lorsqu'il y avait
des épidémies
elle opérait
dans sa maison
un hôpital
pour guérir
les malades.
And Martin
called her
the morning star
of Wittenberg
et Martin
l'appelait
l'étoile du matin
de Wittenberg
because she
would rise
at 4 o'clock
every morning
to take care
of her responsibilities.
She was
truly the glory
of Martin Luther.
And I am
confident
that he
accomplished
far more
by having
a wonderful
help me
like Katie
than he
would have
alone.
Et je suis
convaincue
que Martin
Luther
a accompli
beaucoup plus
grâce à cette
aide précieuse
de sa femme
Katie
qu'est-ce qu'il
aurait pu
le faire
tout seul.
Ladies,
do you
help your
husbands
accomplish
the things
God
has called
them to do?
Mesdames,
est-ce que
vous aidez
vos maris
à accomplir
les choses
que Dieu
l'a appelé
à faire?
Or do
you hinder
him
in his
work
because
you're
always
demanding
things
of him?
Ou est-ce
que vous
l'entravez
dans son
travail
parce que
vous demandez
toujours
plus de lui
pour vous?
Do you
add to
his
credibility
and the
honor
of his
name?
His
reputation
and his
ministry?
Or do
you
bring
shame
to him?
And
lastly,
a Christian
wife
is a
helper
to her
husband
as an
heir
together
of the
grace
of life.
co-héritière
de la
grâce
vie.
I love
this
beautiful
title
that we
can give
it.
I'll have
my
read
1 Peter
De
même,
vous,
Marie,
vivez
avec
elle
selon
la
connaissance
en donnant
honneur
à la
femme
comme
au
sexe
plus
faible
et
comme
étant
co-héritière
de la
grâce
vie,
afin
que
vos
prières
ne
soient
pas
en
travers.
We
are
heirs
together
of
the
grace
of
life.
Men
and
women
have
been
given
equal
access
to
the
grace
of
God
and
the
promises
of
God.
We
have
the
same
privilege
of
prayer
and
drawing
from
the
scriptures.
We
have
the
same
privilege
of
God
and
that
being
the
case,
most
important
thing
you
can
do
in
your
marriage
and
in
your
ministry
is to
cultivate
your
own
walk
with
God.
feed
yourself
the
word
of
God.
Spend
time
in
worship
and
prayer
every
day.
to
worship
and
prayer
because
the
greatest
thing
you
can
do
for
your
marriage
is to
continue
to
grow
in
your
knowledge
of
and
your
love
for
the
Lord
Jesus.
The
thing
important
you
can
do
in
your
marriage
is to
continue
to
grow
in
your
love
and
!
we
should
live
joyfully
with
our
closest
companion
on
earth.
We
will
face
many
trials
and
troubles
on
this
journey.
And
so
being
fellow
heirs
of the
grace
of
life
means
that
we
will
comfort
and
encourage
one
another.
And
we
will
support
the
and
when
we
are
taking
the
time
to
feed
ourselves
scripture
and
to
spend
time
in
prayer,
when
there
is
mutual
encouragement
and
consolation
in
marriage,
when
we
are
enjoying
this
life
as
co-travailleurs
for Christ,
what
peace
and
love
joy
will
permeate
our
homes.
In
the
mid-1800s,
Charles Spurgeon
pastored
the
Metropolitan
Tabernacle
in London,
England.
He
recorded
that
coming
home
one
evening
late,
which
was
his
normal
practice.
says,
!
On
the
way
home,
he
had
the
thought,
should
I
be
spending
more
time
with
my
children?
And
it
is
important
for
fathers
to
spend
time
with
their
children.
But
that's
not the
point of
this
illustration.
He
said
as he
entered
the
home
and
started
up
the
stairs,
he
could
hear
his
wife's
voice.
She
was
teaching
their
voice
the
word
of
God
and
praying
with
them.
And
he
thought,
she
frees
me
to
do
what
God
has
called
me
to
do.
Now,
Charles
Spurgeon's
wife,
Susanna,
was
very
devoted
to
the
Lord.
She
was
known
for
her
support
of
her
husband's
ministry.
Even
though
she
was
an
invalid
for
the
last
years
of
her
life.
this
is
what
she
once
wrote
in
a
letter
to
Charles.
!
It was
ever
the
subtle
purpose
of
my
married
life.
It
was
ever
the
subtle
of my
married
life.
That
I
should
never
hinder
Charles
from
fulfilling
his
engagements.
never
pleading
my
own
ill
health
as a
reason
why
he
should
stay
home
with
me.
And
I
thank
God
now
that
he
enabled
me
to
carry
out
this
determination.
And
I
rejoice
that
I
have
no
cause
to
approach
myself
with
being
a
drag
on
the
swift
wheels
of
his
consecration.
Because
of the
diligence
and
faithfulness
selflessness
of
Susanna
Spurgeon,
she
gave
the
world
Charles
Spurgeon.
Spurgeon
and
we
are
still
being
encouraged
and
inspired
challenged
by
his
sermons.
And
we
continue
to
be
encouraged
and
inspired
to
be
inspired
by
his
sermons
until
today.
Like
the
grateful
husband
in
Proverbs
31,
this is
what
Charles
Spurgeon
wrote
to his
wonderful
wife.
Like
Charles
Spurgeon
said
in
Proverbs
31,
none
know
how
grateful
I
am
for
you.
in
all
I
have
ever
done
for
God
you
have
had
a
large
share.
For
in
making
me
so
happy
you
have
fitted
me
for
service.
Not
an ounce
of
power
has
ever
been
lost
to
the
good
cause
because
of
you.
I
have
served
the
Lord
far
more
and
never
less
for
your
sweet
companionship.
Do
you
see
Susanna
Spurgeon
by
his
own
admission
play
the
large
part
in
the
ministry
of
Charles
Spurgeon?
She
did
not
play
the
piano
in
the
church.
Although
there's
nothing
wrong
with
that.
I
wish
could
play
the
piano.
She
did
not
teach
women's
ministries.
She
did
not
head
up
the
children's
ministry.
She
played
a
large
part
in
Charles
Spurgeon's
ministry
because
she
made
him
so
happy.
she
freed
him
to
do
what
God
had
called
him
to
do.
I've
talked a lot
about
attitudes
and we
need to
pray
and ask
the
Lord
to
give
us
humble
loving
servants
hearts.
We
need to
also
realize
that
we
help
our
husbands
a great
deal
by making
our
homes
a place
of
pleasant
joy
and
peace.
we
have
to
realize
that
we
have
a great
role
in
making
our
families
a
peaceful
and
pleasant
for
them.
But I
would like
to
close
by giving
you
just
a
few
practical
ways
you can
help
your
husband
in
his
ministry.
The
first
one
is
the
most
important.
That
is
pray
for
him.
your
husband
will
face
trials
and
disappointments
temptations
that only
the Lord
can help
him endure.
Regularly
ask your
husband
how can
I
specifically
pray for
you.
him
multiple
times
during
the
day.
You see
no one
knows
him
like
you
do.
No
one
knows
his
struggles
like
you
do.
No
one
knows
the
burdens
he
carries
like
pray
for
specific
needs
in a
way
that
no
one
else
can.
Secondly
pray
with
him.
Pray
together
each
day
for
the
needs
of
your
family
and
your
church
family.
again
there
are
needs
in
your
congregation
that
only
God
can
meet.
Pray
with
your
husband
for
each
person
and
each
family
in
your
church.
Pray
for
each
ministry
he
is
involved
in.
impliqués.
You
can
help
him
carry
his
burdens
by
consistently
praying
for
him
and
with
him.
Thirdly
help
him
fulfill
his
biblical
qualifications.
First
Timothy
and
Titus
chapter
give
specific
qualifications
for
the
elders
in
the
church.
And
there
are
a
number
of
those
responsibilities
that
you
are
uniquely
designed
to help
them
fulfill.
There
are
a
number
of
these
responsibilities
to help
your
husband
to
fulfill.
A
bishop
or
an
elder
in
the
church
must
be
respected
by
people
outside
of
the
church.
As I've
already
mentioned,
you can
enhance
his
reputation
!
with
your
character
or
you can
diminish
his
reputation
!
A
church
leader
must
manage
his own
household
well.
!
That
is
very
difficult
for
a
married
man
with
children
to
do
alone.
He
needs
your
help
in
training
and
disciplining
the
children.
need
You
can
be a
great
encouragement
to your
husband
as he
seeks
to
lead
the
family.
You
can
affirm
him
as he
makes
decisions
and you
can
thank
him
for
his
leadership.
A
church
leader
is
to
show
hospitality.
Again
you're
a
key
player
in
that
role.
Do
you
cheerfully
open up
your
home
to
guests?
Inviting
people
over
for a
simple
meal
or
fellowship
a
Bible
study
will
compliment
your
husband.
Inviter
des
personnes
pour
un
repas
simple
or
an
Bible
or
a
time
at
home
will
accomplish
this
role.
I've
seen
women
who
complain
every
time
their
husbands
want
to
have
someone
over.
I've
seen
women
who
complain
every
time
their
husband
want
to
invite
someone
to
home.
That's
part
of
our
calling
in
ministry
is
to
extend
hospitality.
It's
part
of
our
call
in
ministry
!
It's
to
be
hospital
to
!
So
dear
!
sisters,
I pray
the
Lord
will
grow
every
one
of
us
into
humble
servants
for the
Lord.
May
he
give
us
grace
to
be
faithful
co-heirs
of
the
grace
of
life
for
the
sake
of
our
marriages,
families,
and our
churches,
and most
importantly
again,
for the
glory
of
God.
Amen.
Thank
you.